after eight years as serving as an
interpreter for the US military in
Afghanistan and being credited with
saving the lives of at least five
soldiers Jennison War II officially
became a an American citizen today
national security correspondent Jennifer
Griffin shares his story today I became
US citizen
Janis Shamari worked for years as a
combat translator alongside the 82nd
airborne facing threats from the Taliban
for working with US troops he arrived in
the u.s. seven years ago today he and
his family were rewarded for his duty he
and his two children became US citizens
acting DHS Secretary Ken Cuccinelli
oversaw the ceremony during his service
he saved the lives of five American
soldiers one was this American soldier
in Ghazni province
I saw much Ziller that he was alive in a
ditch and there were two Taliban behind
him to to kill him and I shot this two
Taliban 18,000 Afghans who worked for
the US military are awaiting visas
despite bipartisan support they've had
to lobby Congress and the State
Department to honor the special
immigrant visa program passed by
Congress in 2009 that authorizes 4,000
visas a year for those who helped the US
military a recent State Department
Inspector General report suggested the
backlog has been made worse because
there is only one person at the State
Department overseeing the program it
took three years to get my visa this
process is getting like much longer and
most of them the the got killed by
Taliban waiting for their visa Fox News
first reported two years ago on no one
left behind the veterans nonprofit that
helps bring Afghan combat translators
who risk their lives for American troops
to the US and supports them with
donations as they restart their lives my
kids were very excited last night before
they go to sleep they asked me that if
we wake up tomorrow morning we'll be a
youth citizen I was like yes you guys
should be you citizen tomorrow
Janice Chen wari is still supporting the
US military
working for a defense contractor who
provides rescue beacons for missing
sailors Brett Jennifer Griffin at the
Pentagon Jennifer thank you